il se balade en vélo pour séduire les
guyancourt toi avec sa liste ensemble
agissons pour guyancourt
rodolphe baril s'est lancé dans sa
campagne avec une liste sans étiquette
qui se veut ouverte à tous l'objectif
c'est d'aller à la rencontre des lieux
en courtois donc il ya plusieurs modes
on a décidé nous d'y aller à vélo parce
que à la villa n'est pas si grande que
ça et c'est plus simple pour pour poser
place et puis comment plus d'un point de
vue écologique on veut réduire
l'empreinte carbone de la commune
on va pas non plus à nous déplacer en
voiture donc comme la ville n'est pas
très grande
on se déplace en vélo de quartier en
quartier donc on a fait ça la semaine
dernière et puis ça a super bien marché
distribution de tracts à la sortie des
commerces une technique qui ne marche
pas tout le temps mais qui séduit
certains habitants entraînant des
échanges constructifs
jean charles perrin donc forcément c'est
plus facile de la fin de voir des gens
sur le terrain enfin ceux de les
rencontrer
je vais être interpellé d'avoir un peu
de temps d'avoir cinq minutes je peux
aura daïra élus de la majorité depuis
plus de 18 ans à guyancourt a rejoint la
compagne de rodolphe baril ne trouvant
plus sa place auprès de l'équipe
municipale
elle se tourne désormais vers les
municipales 2020 avec une liste sans
étiquette
j'étais parti pour ne plus reprendre
pour faire de la politique que j'étais
sur le site de chaque candidat j'ai fait
des réunions publiques de chaque
candidat et donc j'ai rencontré une sur
le baril à la tête de la musique tout
simplement je me suis présentée à lui
la liste sans étiquette ensemble
agissons pour guyancourt de rodolphe
baril se présentera face à françois
morton le maire sortant
grégory pape de la république en marche
et décidons ensemble avec lui en course
en tête de liste pour l'instant